hello
now we sing
no
i pledge allegiance
to the flag
of the united states of america
and to the republic for which it stands
a nation under god
indivisible with liberty and justice for
all we will now say god bless america
god
bless
land that i love
stand beside her
and guide her
to the mountains
from the mountains
to the prairies
to the oceans
white will fall
[Music]
god bless america
my own sweet
home
god
america
my home
sweet
home
oh my god
right
you want to mount it
[Applause]
let us pray
almighty god
fountain of all good
kindle in us your love
so that we may be strengthened
not to be conformed to the world
but to be transformed by even this
moment of time lived in eternity
open our eyes that we may see
our ears that we may hear
[Music]
our hearts that we might truly live
[Music]
as we commemorate the birth of dr martin
luther king jr
may we resolve to also overcome
[Music]
and become
all that we can
through our lord and savior
amen
next on the program ladies and gentlemen
we will have a musical selection
by the woodrow wilson senior high school
and i would like to say this that this
is a very serious occasion here for the
department of agriculture remembering dr
king in the american dream and it is
very important to us on the diets that
everyone out there give us your
uninvited attention until the program is
over thank you very much
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
oh
[Music]
um
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
hey
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen
we will now have the occasion
and recognition
and especially recognition by the
director
of the office of minority affairs the
office who is sponsoring this program
the honorable izzy doro rodriguez
[Applause]
good morning
thank you for coming to the united
states department of agriculture
some time ago
secretary john block
secretary for the united states
department of agriculture
decided to honor dr martin luther king
for his services
to all america
with the designation of a commemorative
oak tree on the mall
this was a unique occasion for this is
the first time
that such an event had occurred on the
mall
the reason that the ceremony has been
appropriately set on the mall in honor
of dr king
and for his service to america is that
throughout his years as head of the
southern christian leadership conference
king insisted that the civil rights
movement be both non-violent and in the
best interest of the united states
he stated his vision most vividly for
america in august 1963
when during his march on washington he
asserted from the steps of the lincoln
memorial a half mile down the mall from
where we are now sitting and standing
and i quote i have a dream that one day
this nation will rise up and live out of
the the true meaning of its creed behold
these truths to be self-evident that all
men are created equal
i have a dream that my four little
children will one day live in a nation
where they will be not be judged by the
color of their skin but by the content
of their character this is our hope
under the leadership of secretary john
block
the united states department of
agriculture is moving forward to affirm
this hope 20 years after dr king's
memorable speech
thus
the purpose of this occasion is not only
to remember a great person or even a
great american it is to reaffirm in all
of us that the constitutional civil
rights
laws they're emanating from
are for all americans it is to reaffirm
dr king's desire that our nation be one
where
all are judged
not by color ethnic background sex
handicap status but by their character
he advocated that we must make the
performance and ability of a person
not the color of his skin or the accent
of their voice be the indicator
of achievement
as one
who sought to better the conditions of
all america it is appropriate the united
states department of agriculture so
honored dr king with the commemorative
tree
so we must pause in his honor and
recognize usda employees who are moving
forward to fulfill dr king's hope
and i ask the leaders of the respective
groups who are organized here the four
of respective groups are organized here
in the united states department of
agriculture to please stand
mr stewart jameson liaison for the
american indian activities united states
department of agriculture
[Applause]
dr yvonne blanchard freeman form on
blacks in agriculture
[Applause]
mr richard c fartuni
hispanic american cultural effort
[Applause]
and this
anish dwigen women in action task force
and i don't see you here oh i'm sorry
there you are excuse me
[Applause]
from the united states department of
agriculture i welcome you and thank you
for coming to this ceremony
[Applause]
is julia mcgirt in the audience
okay we will be favored by another
selection from the woodrow wilson senior
high school
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
the song
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
trump
[Music]
we
are
[Music]
oh
[Music]
is
[Music]
we prayed
[Music]
um
hmm
[Music]
so
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen
it gives me honor to introduce the man
who will in turn introduce our keynote
speaker
dr samuel j cornelius former
administrator of the food and nutrition
services here at the department of
agriculture
secretary of agriculture john r block
recognized his talents and realized that
he was needed in the office of the
secretary he was promoted last week in
the office of the secretary as a special
assistant
truly a man of scholar in our midst
ladies and gentlemen
the honorable samuel j cornelius special
assistant to the secretary of
agriculture
[Applause]
thank you very much
deputy secretary elaine distinguished
dias guests
friends of the department of agriculture
employees of the department of
agriculture
those of you who are interested
spectators
and all the others in the house
i want to express my deep appreciation
to the committee for asking me to
introduce
your speaker and mine for this afternoon
before i do that i want to commend
your master's ceremonies mr armstrong
williams
who has done a yeoman's job in helping
to pull this program together
and it was through his principal efforts
that all of you are here today
for the sole purpose of listening to the
speaker
because he interceded
and secured the speaker for you
[Applause]
it does not take one long to understand
that change comes about when someone
steps forward
and dares to do something different
we have witnessed this kind of activity
in most of our daily lives
in religion
in art
in government
and yes in entertainment also
the ability to laugh at ourselves
during what we may consider to be
our tense moments in our lives
has helped bring about that change in
each of us
following the domestic reconstruction
period of the 60s
it was your speaker in mind today
who stepped forward
and dared to do something different
his stage presentations
brought about the question
of race
and brought it out of the closet of
darkness and despair
into the ray of sunlight and hope
this openness by you mr speaker
in front of all america
enabled all of us
to lower our
voices reduce the tension
and step back and take a look at
ourselves
history will record
that from that day forward
much of the progress was made between
the races
in this country and for that
this country owes you a debt of
gratitude mr speaker
your speaker was born in peoria illinois
the state where the secretary hails from
and after serving in the united states
army
he returned to peoria illinois
and he found work playing the piano
and singing in various local nightclubs
he gradually
added comedy to his routines
to his act
[Applause]
and was soon performing throughout
the midwest
and the eastern part of this country
i'm reading it just like you wrote it
[Applause]
mr pryor received his first television
exposure
on the merv griffin
show and that was followed by
appearances on ed sullivan
and the johnny carson shows
his talents eventually brought him to
hollywood
[Music]
and feature films and his first major
role being that of piano man
in the
1972 movie
lady sings the blues
while continuing his film acting
he also contributed his writing skills
to several award-winning television
shows
the flip wilson show
and the lily tomlin special
in addition
our speaker has recorded six
hugely successful
record albums
[Applause]
his most recent movies
include live on sunset strip
some kind of hero
[Applause]
and the toy
he also stars in superman 3 which is
scheduled to be released this summer
on a serious note our speaker was a
participant
during the civil rights movement here in
washington d.c
in the poor people's march which many of
you were in
in 1968
there's one other thing that i know
about our speaker which he does not know
that i know
and that is this
this is particularly important to those
of us in washington dc
because our speaker is one of the strong
supporters
and backers
of the charles m drew memorial hospital
in los angeles california
so it is with great pleasure
and a rare
and particular privilege for me
to have this opportunity to introduce to
you richard pryor
the greatest federal employees in the
world
here in the department of agriculture
and i want you to know before you return
back to your home in los angeles and
over to hawaii
that we are particularly pleased that
you took time out from your busy
schedule
to be with us today
ladies and gentlemen
our speaker for martin luther king's
birthday observance this year
the internationally known
richard
pryor
[Applause]
thank you
thank you
thank you very much
ladies and gentlemen and distinguished
guests
i am very
happy that i was invited here to the
department of agriculture
[Music]
you have to be quiet to hear me
i am very happy
that i was invited here to the
department of agriculture
commemoration of dr martin luther king
jr's birthday
and i've been asked to say a few words
i was in hawaii when i got the phone
call to come here and i was perplexed
because i was wondering why
me
i
certainly am not as eloquent as dr king
i do not
represent
a majority of people in any and lead any
struggles
my heart is good
i'm a good person
i do the best i can
when i'm not doing the worst i can
and i had to think about whether to come
here today and what it was about
and i want to say something about that i
said
i would not want to do anything
that would cast
light on the memory of dr martin luther
king
i would not want to be a party to
anything to embarrass the millions
of black and white people in america
who has struggled to make it possible
that i can stand here today
i never rode on a bus in my life
and took the abuse that some of you out
there took
and i
was flying
on a plane here
from california
and i was reading a book about dr king
and there were pictures in the book
and it brought back memories of that
time for me
and it swelled my heart up
with joy and pride
to think
of the courageousness of every person
who participated in that time
you may not know how brave you were to
do that
to sit there and take abuse and be spat
upon
hit in the head with clubs
stone ugly words thrown at you
and keep your dignity and remain
non-violent
i was one of those people who said that
if anyone ever did that to me
i'd stab him in the eye
and hit him in the head with a brick
that's because i was frightened
i was too frightened to go down to
mississippi
alabama
georgia
i was too scared to sit in the church at
night
and plan
meetings i was too frightened to be a
part of that
but if it wasn't for you people
who were down there and did that
believe me i know in my heart
that i wouldn't be here today
[Applause]
[Applause]
today is a day to honor a great man
who had great vision
and he believed in non-violence
he believed in hope and
faith and today is also about
a black woman
in montgomery alabama one day
was tired
her neck was hurting her body ate from
the work she was doing that day
and she got on the bus
she sat down when she saw a seat
and they asked her to move to the back
she was tired
and she was tired of all of it
she said no
not gonna move me
it's wrong
and because that lady mr rosa
parks did that
it started everything that is happening
here today
[Applause]
and we owe miss rosa parks
a great
amount of gratitude
it is also about james merritt
it's about bobby kennedy
it's about medgar evers
it's about malcolm x
it's about roy wilkins and it's about
ralph abernathy
it's about yuri newton too
it's about eldridge cleaver
it's about every black human being who
tried to make a difference
it's about
the three civil rights
people who were murdered in mississippi
who gave their life for something they
believed in
you don't understand what that's like
you had to imagine the horror those men
went through for standing up for
something they believed in
and they died for it
and i honor them
and i thank them and i'm forever
grateful for them
so i'm here
i had a speech all written and i was
nervous about saying it and right for
last year because i don't make speeches
i'm a comedian
and i'm a professional a professional
comedian
and as you can see i can't even talk
very good when i'm not making jokes
[Music]
[Applause]
i like to also say a few words about
martin luther king's mentor
great man mahatma gandhi
who
was the leader in non-violence
and mahatma gandhi said
for a non-violent person
the whole world is one family
he will thus fear no one
nor
will others fear him
and that means something when you're
non-violent
when you're involved when you care about
what's going on around you
when you don't run
when you see your fellow brother or
sister
being abused no matter what color he is
you can't stand for that because next
it'll be you and you'll be looking for
someone to help you and to be no one
there
you know there are a lot of good people
in the world and in america especially
and there's a great
feeling i sense in the world that all
white people
are bad
well that'd be easy to think and that'd
be easy to say but that would be foolish
and stupid
because it is not true
it is not true you look around you every
one of us knows someone who is good
who is different race a different creed
or different sex
the world is changing whether people
want it to or not
and it doesn't matter
what political party
you're associated with it's about being
good to people
but mostly it's about being good to
yourself
and it's very hard to be courageous and
stand up for what's right
and all of you ladies and gentlemen here
today must believe that or you wouldn't
be here
last night i was at dinner at
uh samuel connie is home him and his
wife and i thank you for that it was
very nice to be there and there was some
beautiful people
and one man in particular
that i had
a pleasure of speaking to was mr tim
alexander alexander senior who's sitting
here in the audience tonight
he's a black man who is
72 years old today and for
50 years he has owned an insurance
company the largest black insurance
company in america
and he he was the man who
got insurance for dr martin luther king
and people involved in the movement for
their automobiles when no other
insurance company in america would be
involved and insure them
he went about and put his whole business
on the line to guarantee that it was
insurance
for for dr king and and the people
involved with him
mr alexander
[Applause]
[Applause]
some of the things you said last night
made me think in my heart and it made it
easier for me to be here today
but mr alexander said
that because some of us have been able
to shake the shackles of racism
and bigotry
and to rise above our so-called station
and to live a better life
because of the struggles
of other peoples
there's one thing that we should not do
is become overwhelmed
[Applause]
because
if you are black
in america
you got a problem
we all have a problem i don't give a
damn about what we do
what kind of work we do
we got a problem
i know it i know that no matter how
black and african i am in my heart and
soul that there are millions
of evil white men out there who control
this society call me a [ __ ]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
and you and i know there are no [ __ ]
[ __ ] gone forever
now we are free
and that brings about a responsibility
we are free
to starve to death
you are free to go to work and better
your condition
if you do better your condition don't
ever forget to look over your shoulder
reach out your hands
and pull
someone else along with you
so in honor of
the great man dr martin luther king jr
my last words i'd like to say
that dr martin luther king's
holiday has got to come out of the
closet
and we
black americans and white americans who
struggle through
the turbulent times of the 60s will not
be satisfied
until his birthday is a national holiday
know
that we are not alone
in the world
black people of america
i know times have changed
the white liberal so-called
establishment
have other games to play now
they have era
right
the nuclear freeze
they have
el salvador
brazil argentina colombia
they have other things they have moved
on because in the 60s when we got
militant we told them we didn't need
them
so they took us at our word
well now we know that ain't true
we need everybody because we got a
problem
we need help
we need to help each other and help
anybody who is helping us
we have africa
africa is free
africa is liberating they liberated
themselves through armed struggle
because they had to
but they are there to help us
there are a hundred million black people
in africa who are waiting for us to stop
saying well africans don't like us
they're reaching out for us all we got
to do is tell them we have a problem
we want your help any way you can help
us
you know the world is 3 billion people
2 billion of them are people of color
so we're not alone
[Music]
and we will as martin luther king said
we will overcome because we will live
the truth and do what is right
and i honored i am honored to have been
chosen to be here today
i hope i have done this moment
well in what i have said and i'm i meant
the things from my heart
and it's not about me it's about me
being here
to say that i'll be glad
when martin luther king jr's birthday
is a national holiday thank you
[Applause]
is
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen we have a special
treat for you
we will be entertained right now by the
distinguished julia mcgirt and company
she will sing an old negro spiritual or
a song of her choice at this moment and
also following the deputy secretary
remarks ladies and gentlemen it is my
pleasure to present julia mcgirt and
company and she is very good
[Applause]
[Music]
first off i'd like to say that it is an
honor to be here and especially
following
such a great man as mr richard hire
himself
and we are also here to honor mr king
[Music]
just
[Music]
[Music]
who got choosing
[Music]
just like me and you
[Music]
oh
[Music]
to you
[Music]
when you place it
[Music]
[Music]
and he chooses
people
just like me and you
who are willing
to do
[Music]
that will give him
[Music]
[Music]
hey
[Music]
[Music]
my
me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh yes he chooses
[Applause]
[Music]
that will give me
[Music]
all you got to do is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
when you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen
um
we will have one more number from julia
i feel she's gonna do
we don't want to displease our
distinguished audience
so
i think julia would probably sing going
up yon
[Applause]
this will be her last song
[Music]
yep
[Music]
where i am
[Music]
just the way
[Music]
just where
i am
[Music]
is
[Music]
is
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
is
[Music]
oh
[Music]
i am
[Music]
yes
[Applause]
[Music]
i said
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
is
[Music]
is
[Music]
i am
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello
[Applause]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
the honorable richard lane deputy
secretary of the united states
department of agriculture
thank you very much armstrong
you know this building
this building has been here for about 60
years
and it's never seen anything like this
[Applause]
before i think it's great and i'm
delighted to
come here today
on behalf of the secretary of
agriculture who is out of town
and to
bring you his greetings
and to tell you how pleased we are
to have participated in this celebration
of martin luther king's birthday
you've had some
you had
really a tremendous
speech
you've had
great introductions
wonderful singing and i'm not going to
give a speech except to say that we are
delighted
speaking on behalf of the secretary
that you would get together here we're
honored that you richard pryor would
come
we think it's just been wonderful
we have
a plaque
which will be placed on an oak tree
out on the
mall on that
area the the south west
corner a plaque which
i think uh i'd like to read to you it
says on this and this will be
you'll be able to read this yourselves
after it's been put on the tree
the ultimate this is a quote from martin
luther king jr
the ultimate measure of a man is not
where he stands in moments of comfort
and convenience but where he stands at
times of challenge
this tree is named in honor of dr king
on january 14
1983
and signed john r block secretary of
agriculture
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
as you may have noted in your program
there is a wreath been placed in front
of that tree
so as you leave today if you would like
to look you can tell which tree it is
we have also from the department of
agriculture a certificate of
appreciation
awarded to richard pryor ambassador of
entertainment in appreciation
[Applause]
and appreciation for your outstanding
contribution to the united states
department of agriculture's martin
luther king day observance thank you
very much
[Applause]
and to all of you who
participated in this program thank you
a special thanks
to rod
to armstrong to sam
to all of you julia
richard
on behalf of the secretary i thank all
of you very very much
[Applause]
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen ladies and
gentlemen mr
mr pride will like have one final
comment before you exit in the days
[Applause]
i i'd just like to say thank you very
much for this award for your kindness
and
remember it's all of us all people
thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]